hey there friends so check this out this
is an exercise that I've been using
lately to warm up with my timing and
direction transitions as well as getting
my PO dance involved as well all the
pieces move together and I really really
love it I get to move back and forth
between two timing and Direction modes
and integrate po dance into it so that
is what I want to share with you in this
video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to be looking into
one of my favorite transition drills
that I've come up with lately and one
that integrates them deeply into po
dance but before we do I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys jug L calling
pyro ter light toys spinballs and Ultra
poy for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission all right so transitions usually
when I'm teaching people how to get back
and forth between different po moves I'm
doing so by teaching them how to use
stalls in order to get there the reason
for this is pretty simple I think stalls
just look really cool and they can be
very percussive as well as being a kind
of uh jumping off point for getting into
plane breaking later on however they're
not always the best call one of my
students these past few months is
somebody who mostly uses programmable
poy and if you've used programmable poy
you know that when you perform stalls
they kind of Wiggle around a little bit
the weight distribution isn't what it is
when you're using such aoy that all the
weight is kind of focused into the end
so this presented a little bit of a
problem in teaching her how to do
transitions because really the only
options that we had left were to use
pendulums but as it turned out there was
a hidden opportunity in using
transitions in this way and I'm going to
show you what it was all right so the
first step is I'm going to teach you a
basic transition drill that I gave to
this same student namely we're going to
work our way back and forth between
together opposite and together same
using nothing but pendulums so to start
with just get the poy in your right hand
spinning counterclockwise like it would
be if you were performing a forwards
butterfly and what you're going to do is
you're going to kind of take away the
momentum on it so it just swings off to
the side and then swing it back around
clockwise when you want to switch back
you take away some of the momentum and
let it go into a pendulum out to the
side and bring it back around
counterclockwise so what we're looking
for is to do a pendulum out to the right
come back around clockwise a pendulum
off to the left come back around
counterclockwise pendulum off to the
right come back around clockwise
pendulum off to the left come back
around
counterclockwise be able to go back and
forth with no more than a single beat in
between each of these pendulums so your
next step is that you're going to try
and bring your left hand po into things
so as you're performing a butterfly with
both poy you're going to go ahead and do
that pendulum off to the right and you
should wind up with both of the Poise
spinning clockwise together in wall
plane you probably want to keep your
hands at least a Poise withth AP part to
make sure that the poy cannnot run into
each other or into either one of your
arms or hands from here you perform
another pendulum with your right hand
sweeping underneath the left and bring
it back around counterclockwise to bring
you back into a butterfly again that's
the right hand goes out into a pendulum
and you bring both hands around
clockwise right hand is a pendulum under
to the left and you come back around and
Butterfly it's going to take some work
at first to be able to execute that
pendulum with only one hand at a time uh
one thing that might help honestly is if
you focus more on just keeping the left
hand going even if the right hand
doesn't execute the pendulum perfectly
just keep that left hand going and then
you can bring the right hand po back
around in the proper direction again we
kind of just keep the left hand going
while the white the right hand stops and
we bring it back around into butterfly
ultimately goal is to be able to go
straight back and forth like so okay now
we have to learn how to do the same
thing on the left so what that's going
to look like is we go ahead and start
spinning the POI clockwise like it would
be if we were performing a butterfly and
we're going to go ahead and execute a
pendulum out to the left and then let
the pois swing back around
counterclockwise we then want to do a
pendulum off to the right and let the PO
come back around clockwise wise so
pendulum to the left counterclockwise
pendulum to the right clockwise pendulum
to the left
counterclockwise pendulum to the right
clockwise again you want to be able to
go through and do no more than a single
beat as you go back and forth when you
really get this exercise down and then
of course our next exercise is to go
ahead and try and keep the right hand
POI spinning while the left poy goes off
and does these pendulums like so as you
go out to the left you bring the left
hand back and we wind up with both of
the pois spinning counterclockwise then
the left hand po swings under the right
in a pendulum and comes back around in a
butterfly so we go left out to the left
we wind up with both with both Po and
wall plane spinning in together same
counterclockwise and then the left hand
swings onto the right to bring us back
into butterfly left off to the left we
go into wall plane counterclockwise
left off to the right and we come back
around in butterfly just like with the
right hand you may find it useful to
really just focus on keeping the right
hand spinning while the left po just
stops and then bring it back around in
the in the uh proper direction and then
do the same thing once again focus on
keeping the right hand spinning and then
bring the left hand around into a
butterfly cool if you get that down
there's only one step left before we're
ready to start bringing the footwork
into things so the next step of this
exercise is we're going to work on
trying to Alternate which hand does the
pendulum so rather than thinking it's
going to be right hand as a pendulum and
then right hand ases the pendulum again
we're instead going to think right hand
does a pendulum and then left hand does
a pendulum right hand does a pendulum
and then left hand does a pendulum so
this will mean that we're going to
switch back and forth from butterfly to
having both of the POI spinning
clockwise and wall plane and together
same
to having the pois spinning in a reverse
butterfly that is they're coming up
through the middle rather than down
through the middle and then we're going
to switch to having both POI spinning
counterclockwise in wall plane before
finally returning to that butterfly that
we started with once again we do a
pendulum with the right come around
clockwise we do a pendulum with the left
reverse butterfly we do pendulum with
the right counterclockwise we do a
pendulum with the left come back around
clockwise you want to be able to get it
to the point where you only need to do a
single beat with the poy in between each
of these adjustments like so cool so if
all of that is seeming reasonably
intuitive then now it is time to put it
together with our footwork and
specifically we're going to be doing a
little dance move called a chass chass
just means to Chase and uh the way I
think of it is it's almost like a skip
you can either do it front to back
or you can do it side to side like so um
the way I'm thinking of this happening
is you're kind of like doing a little
bit of a leap up and you're kind of
clicking your heels together and when
you come down you're kind of letting the
momentum uh kind of drop down and around
and out in order to uh kind of work it
off and then we come back together click
the heels together and work the momentum
off click the heels together and out
click click the heels together and out
click the heels together and out click
the heels together and out so the next
step is to add the poy into that so as
you may or may not have surmised by now
we're going to be matching up our
movements to either side of the stage
with our hands performing pendulums let
me show you what that's going to look
like here so from butterfly I'm going to
go ahead and do my LEAP and chass and
that is my cue to do the pendulum with
my right hand POI and bring both both
POI back around in clockwise now from
here it's my cue to do the chass back
over to Stage Left boom and to do the
pendulum out with my left hand bringing
the poy around in a reverse butterfly
now this is where things get interesting
because now as I sh say over to Stage
right I'm going to be doing a pendulum
underneath my left hand with my right
hand poy and uh leaning my body over to
the right so there's there's kind of
almost like a little bit of a contrast
in the motion here where I'm moving in
the opposite direction that my PO is but
the thing is as I come back around with
both of my PO spinning
counterclockwise and do the chass over
to stage left I'm going to wind up doing
the same thing with my leftand PO
swinging it under my right hand before I
come back around in a butterfly so what
we get out of this is moments both when
we Shay to the direction of the pendulum
as well as moments when we Shay again
against the direction of the pendulum we
have both moments where we're working
with the PO and against it and I think
that's part of what makes this exercise
look kind of cool visually so Al
together we're looking to chass to the
right come around clockwise chass to the
left reverse butterfly chass to the
right counterclockwise chass to the left
back to Butterfly clockwise reverse
butterfly
counterclockwise
butterfly clockwise
reverse butterfly
counterclockwise and butterfly and of
course if you want to you can really get
into this and throw your momentum around
you can experiment not just with having
the POI kind of spinning at your hands
but by doing full gigantic extensions
with the poy as you're doing these leaps
to either side now personally I have
been finding that this exercise works
best with music so I'm going to go ahead
and throw some on and show you what it
looks like when when I bring it to a
[Music]
beat 5
6 5 6 7 8
[Music]
go
awesome so I hope you all enjoy this
exercise too if you make use of it in
your own practice please post some video
online and make sure to tag me I am
drexfactor on Instagram and Tik Tock as
well as on YouTube and I would love to
see your hard work please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right over here right now if you
enjoy watching these po dance tutorials
these lessons where I take you through
some of the ways I've been developing my
technique and you'd love to see more of
them I'd love to make more of them the
best way that you can make that happen
is by signing up to support my work over
on patreon you can do that over at
patreon.com drexfactor poy doing that
allows me to focus more time on creating
videos rather than having to do other
things that'll bring money in the front
door so I can pay rent and eat and all
that so if this is an effort you want to
see continue
that's the way to make it happen go
check that out please and thank you if
you'd like to learn more about po dance
techniques and how you can combine the
two of them together I have a video on
pot Beret put together with py Trix that
you may enjoy I'll go ahead and link to
that down in the description or up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace